this course will teach you how to deploy
10 of the most popular types of apps
on the three most popular cloud
providers
so if you want to learn to deploy a
specific type of app this course is for
you
in this video we'll create a docker
container for each of these
apps and will deploy the container to
azure aws and google cloud
the result will be the same for all the
apps
so check the timestamps of this video to
select your favorite language
or framework and then select your
favorite deployment platform
so let's start deploying these apps in
this video
we will create a production container
for this
react app and we will deploy it
to google cloud aws and azure
so let's start first i'll create
a file called docker file and
of course make sure you have a installed
docker in your machine
and in the docker file we have to
start from the container itself
what type of container will it be and we
will start with from
this container will be a node container
and here i will specify the version of
node so i will pick 15.4
and i will name it as build
i will explain later why i
named it like this so let's start with
this container we have to specify
the working directory i'll call it
up so you can put whatever you want here
and let's copy the packages
the json to that
working directory so this means we have
to copy
this package.json dot means the working
directory here
so i'll add a star here the star means
that we can add anything in between
package
and json this means that we'll copy
package.json
and also package log.json
so we copied those files then we have to
run
npm install so this is self
explanatory so we have
npm already installed in the container
because
we are using another environment here
so that's why this is
important after we installed
all the packages we have to copy again
all the files to the working directory
so this means
all the other files we have to copy them
to the working directory
and then we have to build the container
so
run npm run build
so if we go to package.json we have a
build
script here and what this
will do it it will create a
distribution folder so let's surround
that command npm
run build
so we can visualize that folder
so we have a built folder here
which will have all the necessary files
and we
completed the first stage so
this will be a multi-uh
stage docker build which means
that we will have another stage
so we have all these files
inside this docker container but we need
only the build folder
so uh there is no need to keep all of
them
we can have a smaller container and
to do to do that we have to
add another from here and this
container will have nginx
so i'll pick the latest version
so if i want the latest version i will
just add
nginx here or i will add the
1.19
and in this nginx
container we need to add here i will
create another directory
nginx
and here i'll create a file nginx
dot conf and
here i'll paste this configuration so
there's a lot of text but you can
copy this file uh on the source code
in the video description so
this is required to access
the file index.html directly
here so the build has index.htm html
and all the javascript files that we
need
so we have to copy this file
to this nginx container
so copy
ngnex nginx.com to
atc ng x
nginx dot com
so we added our own nginx configuration
then and the second step is to add
the build folder to the nginx
html so that's why we named this
as build here so here i will copy
from build
so this is a command from this container
here
which has this build folder
we'll copy up build
we specify the working directory to be
up so
it will make sense that the
build folder is up slash build
and we have to copy this from user
user share
nginx html
and that's it so this is our
docker container to build this react
up in production so
to run this
simply run docker
build i will specify
the name for this container so to
specify the name for the container you
have to add here minus t
and the name of the container i'll
specify it to
up then we need the context which is uh
this directory so we specified with
dot and that's it so we'll build
this docker file and we will assign it
a name to app let's build it
so it's building now the container has
been built
now it's ready to be deployed but before
we deploy it let's see
if this is running fine but by
running it on the browser so to do it
run docker run
our app but we have to specify our
port so minus p here and
the port of our container will be 80. so
this will run on port 80
and uh this is a port of our browser so
i'll put 80 it will work on my machine
but if
it doesn't work on your machine you can
put another port like
888 doesn't matter so i'll put 80 here
and this will
run our docker container now i'll go to
my browser
run here localhost just localhost
because 80 is the default port
and we can see our react app so
we created a docker
container to be deployed now
and now let's deploy it i will close
this
ide because we don't need it anymore
in this video we will create a simple
node app
and we will deploy it to aws azure
and google cloud so let's create it i
will open my terminal
and write npm in it
so i'll pick everything
by default and then i will install
express
so i'll create also
an index so javascript file
index.js here i will
get expresso const express
is equal require express
then i will get so i'll create the
first up is equal to express
and up a get request
to the main route i'll let the function
here
that it will have a request and the
response
and this will be very simple i will just
do response
send hello
world that's it so
super simple in the end i will
listen to port 80.
so i won't start this up so this is
self-explanatory but
i will start this app via a docker
container
because the port 80 is just localhost
and
and it may conflict your browser so
let's create a docker file
the docker file will be very simple so
we need
a node environment and the version is
15.4
so we will specify a working directory
i'll call it
up then we will copy
the package.json so package that json
dot means it will copy to the working
directory
here so in short is dot
i will add a star here so this will take
package.json and also package minus
log.json
so if we do it like this it will copy
both of this
then we will run npm install
because we get from the node environment
then i will copy all the files there so
the first dot means all the files here
and the second dot
is the working directory then the last
command
is node index.js
and that's it so this is our docker file
to build this docker file we have a
first make sure to have install docker
and then
run docker build
uh we need to specify a name for this
docker build i will call it up so this
is a command to
pick a name for the docker container and
then we need dot here which
means this context here so it will
select
this docker file and now it's building
once it is completed let's
so it is completed and
now to see the app on our browser around
docker
run we need to specify the port which
we need to run so
80 is a port inside the docker container
and then the app is our app so in our
browser
i'll put 4 8
so if we run this command
and go to localhost
port 8888 we will see hello world here
so this is uh our
container and now let's get this
up and deployed to aws
azure and google cloud now i will close
also this
window because we don't need it in this
video
we'll create a docker file for this view
app
and deploy that docker container to aws
google cloud and azure so let's start
let's create a docker file
so to build this up we will
use the multi-stage builds in docker
i will explain you what is that so first
we have to
start from node and i will put
the version of node to this version
and i will name this as build
so i will explain later why i named it
like this
first let's specify the working
directory
i'll name it up then
let's copy package.json to the app
so to the working directory this second
dot
means this working directory i will add
a star here
so this will get the package.json and
also
package log.json so
after we got those files we
run npm install
so it will install the node modules then
we'll copy all the files to the working
directory so
all these files will it will be copied
to this working directory
and then we run npm
run build so
this will build this view up
to a distribution folder so
if we run this command npm run build
we'll see a distribution folder will be
created here
so this is a folder and it will have an
index.html
index etc so
[Music]
now what i will do is i'll add another
from here
and i'll get nginx version
1.19
why i'm adding another from here so
this is multi-stage building so
so we don't need
all these folders anymore inside the
door container
inside the docker container we need only
the distribution folder so only this
folder
and to do that first we have to create
the first
stage which we have all the files and
the distribution folder
and then we create
another from here
and first we need an nginx
file so we will use nginx here
let's create directory nginx
and inside i'll create a file nginx.com
here i'll paste this code
so it's a lot of code but i'll provide
the link
in the description of this video so you
can get this code
and to copy that nginx file
we run copy
nginx nginx.conf we have to copy it
to the atc folder nginx
nginx dot conf
so we'll put this file
there then we'll copy
from
build that's why i named it
like this so once we finish
we have a reference for this build
so from that build we want only the
distribution folder so
in the app distribution folder
that's why we named also the working
directory up so
it is in app and also distribution
folder
will copy it to user
share nginx
html and that's it
so uh in the end
we will have a smaller container just
containing
html and javascript and css files
so let's run this container to run this
container
make sure first to have installed docker
and run
docker build
we need to specify the name for this
container i'll call it up
so if you want to name your container
whatever name you want put minus t
and the name here then i will put a dot
which means that it is this
folder here and it will select this
docker file
so with this
our docker is building let's wait till
it's
completed then so it is built now
and to see it on the browser we need to
run it so
run docker run
we need to specify a port so to see it
on our browser i will put
this port to our browser and this
app will run on port 80 since we are
using
nginx here and then we need the name of
our container which is
up so let's run this
and it's running now so if we go to
localhost port 888
we'll see the view up so this is our
container and now i will close
this window now because we don't need it
anymore
now let's deploy this container
in this video we'll create a production
red in sjs docker container
and will push that container to aws
google cloud and azure so let's start
first i want to change
in main.ts the port here to 80
because all our containers will
start with the port 80 and
now let's create the docker file so
also make sure to have installed docker
in your machine
so let's start the build so we need to
start from the node
environment and i'll put the version
15.4
and i'll name it as build
so this is a multi-stage docker build
i will explain that later
[Music]
first let's uh begin with the first
stage so let's begin with node
15.4 and what do we want to do here
let's specify a working directory up
and we want to copy
package.json to the
app so dot means this working directory
also i will add a star here so if i add
a star here
this will get package.json and also
package
log.json so i added to the package.json
now
run npm installed since we are from the
node
environment this npm command is
available
after we finish that we want to copy
everything
to the working directory so this first
dot means all the files here the second
dot means this working directory
after we finish run
npm run build so with this
we build this
nest js up so let's run
npm run build here and see what it
does generate so this will generate this
folder
here so as we can see we have this
folder
and here we have all the necessary files
so in order to
run this on production we have to have
this this folder
and we don't need the other files
that's why we do a
[Music]
like a multi-stage build because
we will create another node environment
here
from node 15.4 also
and in this
node environment we'll specify again the
working directory up so don't confuse
this with this because there are two
different containers
then we'll copy also the
uh here i will copy only package.json
actually
would run npm install
but we need only the production
packages so if we go to package.json
we have dependencies and dev
dependencies
if we run it like this
we will install only the dependencies so
there are fewer packages here and
this node package will be
smaller than this one of course because
we have
less packages then
we'll copy from build
we'll copy the distribution folder so up
dist
so up is the working directory here this
is the folder that we just generated
and we'll copy that to the
dot means our app here dist
so we'll copy the distribution folder
there this distribution folder has a
javascript file so this
needs uh also node modules and
that's it basically so in the end we
will run
the command npm run start
prod so
this is a smaller version of
this one because this will this
other container will have only the
distribution folder
and not modules but only the production
packages
so we don't need all these files
so we created the production ready
nesjs app let's run it so to run it
simply run docker build
we need to specify the name of the
container i'll call it
up so if you want to name a container
you put minus t and the name of the
container
and dot means this folder and it will
select this docker file
so if we run this it will build
our app now let's wait till it's
completed
so it is completed now this container
can be pushed
to the to the cloud
but first let's test it so
to test it we have to run it so docker
run and we have to specify the port the
port inside the docker container is 80
but in our browser
we can put any port we want so i'll put
this port
and the name of the container is up so
we can run
our container like this as we can see
is running successfully and we can go to
localhost
888 and we can see hello world here
so the container is running now
we need to push this
production container to the cloud
and i will close this ide here because
we don't need it in this video we'll
create a production ready docker
container for an angular app
then we'll push this container to aws
azure and google cloud so let's start
first i'll create a docker file
make sure also to have installed docker
in your machine
so we need the environment here so we
need the node environment
and the version that i will put here is
15.4
and i'll name it as build
so we will do a multi-stage docker build
i will explain that
later uh first let's focus from this
node this part here we want to build
our app let's start with the working
directory
you can name it whatever you want i will
call it up
then we'll copy package.json
to the working directory so
i will add also a star here
so this will copy package.json and also
package log.json this dot
means this working directory so once we
add those files there
we run
npm install and since we are using a
node
container we have npm available
so after we install it
then we need to build it to production
so before i run anything here i will i
want to make a change
uh we have ng build here in our scripts
but if we want to build to production we
have to add
crowd here so
what i will do is i will add a new
script prod
and this will be ng
build broad like this
so this will be easier
and now here i will run the command
npm run broad
so this will build our app to production
so i will run that command here also
and let's see what files it does
generate
so now we will
learn why i named it like this
because once we run npm ram pro
it will create some files here
and we don't need these files anymore we
need only the distribution folder
so we created the builds
so not sure why my app doesn't
get the files uh
doesn't matter so let's
add a new from here and this time we
won't
have node but i will add nginx
and the version will be 1.19
so here we want red
node we will simply serve the html files
which i need to refresh
not sure why
they reload so we have the
distribution folder here and we can see
we have index html and these files
so it's located in the distribution
folder angular docker
this is a name of my project by the way
you can name your project whatever
so now we are at
nginx we need also
a directory here nginx
and i will add here a file nginx.conf
here i will paste this nginx code
so i will provide this code in the
description of this video
and let's go to the docker file
i'll copy copy here
nginx nginx.conf
and we'll copy that to adc
nginx nginx
dot conf so dot here
so we have copied that file in this
other container and now we will use
this build here so as i said before
we don't need these files anymore
we need only the distribution folder
since it will serve the index html file
with this javascript
build files so for that
we will copy
from build
we'll copy we have the working directory
is
up here so from up dist
and this has another folder here which
is angular docker in my case
angular docker
and we'll copy that to
so a lot of slash just in case to user
share nginx html
so this way this was a bigger
container since it had not models and
all these files
but this one has only html
and javascript files so its smaller
container
is running on nginx which is serving
only this html file
and we need this nginx we need it
because
when we go to
a specific url we want to redirect
all of them to the index.html so
this is this location otherwise
we'll get an error so
this is a docker file and now let's run
it so
to run this docker file write
docker build
we need to specify a name for this uh
docker file
for this docker container i will specify
to not
to up but you can name it whatever you
want
and we need to build this docker file so
we have to add it
as a dot here so now
is building let's wait till it's
completed
so it failed uh because i forgot one
line here between uh
npm install and npm ramp prod which is
to copy
all the files to the working directory
so my bed there
so this will copy all these files
to this working directory and then we
need to build
to production so now that we fix the
problem let's run it again
so now it was built successfully
and now this container is ready to be
pushed to the cloud
but first let's see it on our browser so
to see it on our browser we have to run
the container so docker
run we need to specify the port
so the port inside the container is
80. in our localhost we can put whatever
part you want
so i will put 8888 so
and then we need the name of our
container which we
named it up so that's it
if we run this and go to our browser
let's go to localhost 88888 and we'll
see the angular app
running so this was our
container that was built now let's push
this container to the cloud and i will
close this
ide because we won't use it anymore
in this video we'll create a production
ready
go file and we'll push it to aws
google cloud and azure so let's start
first let's run go mode in it
i will call the project docker
doesn't matter so
also go to go fiber
framework we won't use this
framework but we will just copy the
hello world
part so we'll create main.go file and
so enable integration here let's create
a
go file main
the package so i'll paste it here
this is uh our main.go file
and of course let's
also get this fiber module here so go
get this
so we got that we
added it on our go mode so we have also
got some so these are important because
we need to add them
to docker so this is our
go up now let's create
the docker file so i'll create a file
here
docker file also make sure to
have docker installed in your machine so
now here we need to
[Music]
specify the environment which this
container will be built
and this will be a golang container
so i'll put the version here which is uh
the latest version for this
time is 1.16
and i'll add the alpine here
which is a version of linux which is the
smallest one
and now let's specify a working
directory
i'll call it up but you can name
name it whatever you want so the working
directory is
up now let's copy go
mods to the app directory so
this other dot means that it will be
copied to this working directory
let's copy also go
some there so we copied this
now we can download them so to download
them we need to run the command
go mod download
so with this all the packages that we
will install
here they will be downloaded also in the
docker container
after that is finished we have to copy
all the files
so this dot means all the files here the
second one
means all the
files will be copied copied to the
working directory
so once we copy everything we
run go
build in the output
will be out dist
so you can name the output as you want
and it will run on this uh
files here so we can run that command
also now so we can test
what it does generate so we have out and
we have a distribution here that we can
use
so uh now
that we have this uh this
exact executable
we run command
which is simply out
dist that's it so you can name it
whatever you want i named it this
and simply we will run this file and
i'll go run
go up will run ok
one last change that i will make which
all the backends needs to listen to port
80. so i don't want to listen to port
3000
i will listen to port 80 but this will
be the port inside the docker container
so don't
worry if this conflicts to your browser
so now that we have built everything
let's run this so to run this
run docker build
we need to name the container i will
name the container
up so to name the container we have to
put minus t
in front of it then we need to add dot
here
which means that it will
search for this folder and it will run
this docker file
so let's build it and now it's building
so it will run all these commands
and let's wait till it's completed
so everything was successfully built and
uh
now we can push this container to the
cloud but
before let's see it on our browser if
everything runs fine
so run docker run
we need to specify the port so the port
inside the docker container was
80 but in our localhost we can put
whatever part we want i will put 888
and then we need the name of the
container which we called it
up so as we can see
the fiber app is running and now
if we go to localhost port
888 we'll see hello world here
so we successfully build the production
ready
container for golang and now let's push
it to the cloud
and i'll close this ide because we don't
need it anymore in this video we'll
create a docker container for as well
app and will push that container to aws
google cloud and azure so let's get
started
first let's create a docker file here
and of course make sure to have
installed the
docker in your machine and here
i will add from node the version
i will specify 15.4 here
and i will name it as build
so this will be a multi-stage build i
will explain later this uh
as build what does this mean and let's
add a working directory
i'll call it up so this is the folder
that will create our project you can
name it whatever you want
and then we'll copy package.json to that
folder
so we'll copy package.json dot means
this working directory
i'll add a star here which means that
we'll get packet.json and also package
log.json so we can add
anything in between the star so
now that we added those run npm
install since we are from a node
environment
this npm will be available
and after npm install is finished let's
copy
everything so this is all these files
and folders
to this working directory so
once we add everything we have to build
so run npm
run build so
this is the first stage so we can run
npm run
build here to see what files does it
generate
so this generates a bundle.js
here on the public folder
so this is what we are gonna do so
once this is generated here
we don't need these other files so we
don't need scripts src
everything so we need only the public
folder we don't need even the node
modules
so that's why we do a multi-stage build
so we can create another container here
nginx the version is 1.19
so this container now
we won't get we
we want to get only the public folder
but first
let's add here i'll add the directory
nginx and
[Music]
inside i'll create a file nginx.conf
and here i will copy this code so
i'll provide this code in the
description of this
video and
we need to copy this
file to copy
nginx nginx.conf to
atc nginx
nginx.conf so we added the configuration
and now we name this build
and we will copy from the build
in the app so app is the working
directory
we want only the public folder
so we go to public folder and will copy
it to
user
share nginx
html so that's it
so before it was uh all
this it was a container with all these
files
so we don't need not models or all these
files here
uh then we created a smaller container
that contains
only the public folder with
the bundle js files
with this we can run
our docker container so let's create it
so to build this
docker file we run docker build
we need to specify the name for this
docker container so
i'll put t minus t
up so up is the name that i
put so you can put whatever name you
want
and dot in the end is we will build
to this uh context
and we will get this docker file and
that's it
so this will build our app let's wait
till it's completed
so it is completed and now this
container is ready to be pushed
to the cloud but before let's uh
test it on the browser so to run it on
the browser on docker
run and we have to specify the port
i will put 888 and the
report inside this docker container is
80.
and the name of the container is up
so it is started and now in our browser
go to localhost port
8888
and we can see hello world and our swelt
app is running so with this
we are ready now to push the container
to the cloud
and i'll close this ide because we don't
need it anymore
in this video we'll build a docker
container for this django
app and we'll push that container to aws
google cloud and azure so let's get
started
so first i'll create here a docker file
so we need to start from python
and the version that i will put here is
3.9
alpine so
this container will have a python
pre-installed
with this version and also alpine is the
smallest
version of linux let's add an
environment
[Music]
variable which is python
and buffered
one this is uh needed in order to see
the logs in our python app
and now let's create a working directory
so
this you can name it whatever you want
all the files
will be added in this app folder
then we need to
install the dependencies so
i will add here a file called
requirements
dot txt and here
i will just add django with this
version so this is our only requirement
and uh we need to copy
that file to the
working directory so this dot means
this working directory so we'll copy
this file to the working directory
and then we need to run the command pip
install minus r i will copy the
file here
so this will install all the
dependencies
inside this container don't forget also
once you add the dependency to update
also your
requirements dot txt
once we install everything we'll copy
all the files so we'll copy everything
here
to this working directory and
that's it so in the end we'll run the
command
python manage that pi
run server
i'll put here the host it needs to be
0.0.0.0
so it should be inside the docker
container so this should be the
the port the whole sorry
and the port should be 80.
why did i change the port to 80
because all our containers
in this project will run on port 80
and i'm reusing videos so that's why i
put 80 but if you want you can put
the normal port 8000 so
let's run this docker file to run this
docker file we have to build do it we
have to build it first
so docker build
and we want to specify the name for this
container so to specify a name put minus
t
i'll call it up and i'll add the dot in
the end which means it will build
in this context and it will select this
docker file
let's run it and as we
see it's building let's wait till it's
completed
so it is built now this container
can be pushed to the cloud but before
let's test it on our browser so to test
it on our browser
run docker run we need to specify a port
so for the back for the container
is 80 as we saw
and in our front in our browser we can
put whatever port we want i will put 888
in the end we need our container which
is up
let's run it as we can see our server
is running and now we can go to our
browser
and type localhost port 8888
and this is our jungle up running so
the container is working fine and now we
are ready to push it to the cloud
i will also close the ide because we
won't use it anymore
in this video we'll create a docker
container for
laravel project and then we will push
the docker container to aws
google cloud and azure so let's get
started
first i'll create here a docker file
and of course make sure to have
installed docker in your machine
and here in the docker file we'll start
from
php the version will be
7.4 fpm
so this is uh the
container that will have a php already
installed
there still we need to install some
other packages
i will paste them here so
these are some libraries that we need to
install
and this is the installation of composer
because composer is not
already installed here and
this is a command that will enable uh
these two extensions in our php.ini file
so that's it after we add everything
that
we need let's specify the working
directory
i'll call it up we need to copy
composer.json
to the working directory so this means
that
this dot means that this composer.json
will be
copied here and
after we got composer.json we need to
run
composer install and we'll add no
scripts here so we will simply
install everything that composer
needs and we want run this
post scripts like this once
so we will simply install everything
and after that we'll copy
all the files here into the working
directory
so now we have everything and we will
simply
run the command php artisan serve
we need to specify also the host
which will be
zero point zero point zero point zero
and also the port two
eighty so we don't need
to put 80 port here but
i need it because i combine multiple
videos
and they all have port 80.
so we finished with the docker file now
we are
we're ready to build it so to build this
docker file
run docker build we need to specify the
name for this docker build
and we can specify a name by adding
minus t
the name i'll put it up but you can name
it whatever you want
in the end dot means this contacts here
and it will search for this docker file
so it will run the docker file and now
is building let's wait till it's
completed
so it is built now this container is
ready to be deployed on the cloud
but before let's test it on our browser
to see if it works
so to run it on our browser run docker
run uh we need to specify a port
so uh the port inside the docker
container is 80
and in our browser you can put whatever
port you want i'll put 888
so in the end we need the name of our
container so we specified it to be
up so this is
our docker run and is running so
if we go to the browser now and go to
localhost
port 8888
we'll see the laravel app running so
the container is running fine now let's
push
this container to the cloud also i'll
close
this ide because we won't use it anymore
this video will create a docker
container for a.net
project and will push that project to
aws google cloud and azure
so let's get started first in this web
api
i will make it just a small change i
will remove this
controller here and the route will be
the empty route and our app will simply
return
the default weather
so that is not important
what is important is to create a new
docker file
so new file docker file
so make sure also to have installed
docker in your machine
and let's start with from
we need the image that we want to start
so
i will write
microsoft container registry
[Music]
microsoft
dot com slash dot net
slash sdk so we'll start
with the version five so
this is uh the container that
will start and it will have i have a sdk
already installed in this container
and i will name it as build
so this will be a multi-stage docker
build and
i will explain it later why i name it
like this
so let's start with the working
directory
i'll name it up so
we you can specify whatever folder that
you want
i will name it like this and here we'll
copy
the c sharp project so all
that see a sharp
project so
like this and we will copy to the
working directory so this
project will be copied to this dot
means this working directory and
after it's copied we run the command dot
net
restore after we run the
that command we will copy all
in that folder again so this will get
all the files here and it will copy
to the working directory and after
we copied all the files we need to
publish
to a dll so to
to do it we run the command run
dot net publish
we need to specify release
and it will the output will be in the
out folder
and that's it for the first stage so
let's run this command in our
local machine to see what this does
generate
so if we run this command
we will get a node folder here
where we will have a lot of files uh the
one that
we are interested is this
dot net docker dll so
we're interested only in this file and
we can ignore
all the other files that's why we use
now
a multi-stage build because
this will contain all the files
and also the output but this other
container that we will build now so from
i'll copy this dotnet
and we will specify asp.net here
this other container will have the same
working directory
but don't confuse this working director
with this one because there are
different containers
and we will copy
from the build so from this
build will copy
up which is the working directory there
out so we'll copy everything
in the out folder to this dot
which is this working directory so
we will we created another container
with only the out
folder so it is a smaller one
and what is left is to add an entry
point
dot net and will execute
dot net docker dll
and that's it so in the end we have a
lighter
docker container which is just a dll
so we can execute it so
we finished with this docker file
let's build it so to build a docker file
run docker build
and we want to specify a name for this
docker build
and we can specify name by adding minus
t
up that is the name that we want to
build
and we will add the context which is a
dot
so this will execute this docker file
so it's building let's wait till it's
completed
so the container has been built and now
we it is ready to be pushed to the cloud
but before
let's test it on our browser to test it
on our browser we have to
run this container we need to specify
the port
so inside of the container the port
is 80 but in our localhost we can put
whatever part we want i'll put 8888
and the name of our container
was up so let's run this
and it's successfully running now so if
we open our browser
and uh right here localhost port
888 we can see
this is a json that is returning this
weather forecast so it's working fine
so this container has been
built and now we need to push it to the
cloud
i will close also this ide because we
don't need it anymore
in this video we'll create a docker
container for a kotlin
app and we'll push that container to aws
google cloud and azure so let's get
started
first i'll remove here the
test folder and
in the resources i'll add the
server port
to 80 so i want to
the all the containers that
i deployed to run on port 80 because i'm
reusing content
but you can you may change it to
the port that you want doesn't matter so
uh i added the port 80 and also i'll add
a controller here so a lot of directory
controllers
and i will create a new kotlin
file so
home controller
so this will be a class
home controller and
it will have a function home
so let's add also
here this should be a rest controller
actually i will paste everything so i
don't want to
import it again so this is our home
controller it will be a rest controller
it will have only one method that will
return hello world
so that's it so this it is this simple
and now we want to
uh create a docker container with
this simple app so let's create a docker
file
so first make sure to have installed
docker in your machine
and here i'll add from
we need the environment will be a gradle
and the version will be seven and the
jdk
will be eight so this is a version that
of the gradle and jdk that i want to
start
i'll name this as build
so this will be a multi-stage docker
build i will explain
that later why i name it like that but
let's focus
first on this part let's specify a
working directory
i'll call it up so you can put
whatever name you want here
so all the files will be created inside
this folder now
so let's copy everything there
so this first dot is all these files
and the second one is this working
directory
once we added everything there we need
to run the command
dot slash gradle
w we will execute this file
build
with the stack trace
so this will generate a build folder
here
let us see it so if i run gradle w
build here this will generate
a build folder so as you can see
we have a build folder now so
what we want here is to go to the libs
and
this is our jar that we want to
execute actually i'll
remove this snapshot to remove that
snapshot
we need to go to gradle that
kotlin to remove this so this
will create a shorter name without the
snapshot
so we don't need now
any of these files except for these
jar files so that's why we created
a multi-stage build because now
we can create another container from
openjdk
and this will be a smaller one
will specify the same working directory
but these are different containers so
don't
worry if they have the same name
will expose the port 80
because we set it to our source folder
and then we'll copy from
the builder will copy
this path so app
build libs
and then we need the name of the
file so i will uh
copy this but we don't need the snapshot
so we remove the snapshot so it
will be like this that jar
so this will be the name of the build
and we'll copy it to this working
directory
and this container only has this jar
and we will just execute it's a command
[Music]
java jar
and i will copy this
name and that's it so this is
the container let's start let's uh run
it
and test it so first we have to build it
so docker
build we need to specify the name for
this
docker build and we can do that by
adding minus t
the name of the container will be up
so we added this and then we need to add
dot which means that it will be in
this context and it will it will execute
this docker file
let's run it so i made a mistake
this is build i forgot a nail here
so now everything is running let's
wait till this is completed
so it is completed now this container
is ready to be published to the cloud
but before let's test it to our browser
to test it to our browser we need to run
the container so docker
run we need to specify the port
so minus p not t and
the port inside the docker container is
80
but in our localhost we can put whatever
we want
i will put 888 and the name of the
container
was up if we run it like this
it will execute it so it's running fine
now let's test it on the browser
localhost
port 8888
we can see hello world here which means
our app
is running fine now let's
deploy this app to the cloud and i will
close this
id because we don't need it anymore
in this video we'll create a docker
container for a deno
app and we'll push it to aws
google cloud and azure so let's get
started
so make sure first to have installed
deno
and i will simply copy this code
i'll create in an empty directory here
a file app.ts
and i will paste this code so
this is a really simple if we run this
up then run up.ts
we need also to add the
net flag
and as we can see it's running on port
8000 so if we go here
local host port 8000 will see
hello world so this is our demo app that
we will
push and uh let's start
now by creating a docker file
make sure also you have docker installed
in your machine
so this will be super simple
we need to come from denoland
deno the latest version
currently is 1.11.0
and we have to specify a working
directory up
and then we'll copy everything
there so this command means
that we'll copy uh upds
to this working directory and
what is left is to simply run the
command that we just
run before which is uh
we don't need to specify deno but we
will
run we'll add the flag
allow net
and the file is up
dot yes and that's it
super simple also i will change
something here
i want to serve it to port 8000 but i
want to serve it to port
80. because
all our docker containers will serve on
port
80 and it's easier for me
for to combine these tutorials
but you can put the port 8000 it's
totally okay now that we have
everything let's run this uh docker file
first
we have to build it so to build it
around docker
build we want we
need the name of the container so
you we specified by minus t and
we'll specify the name of the container
to be up
and then we'll add a dot here which
means it is this context and it will
select
this docker file so let's build
up now it is building
it will be fast once is
downloading everything
so it is completed now
we can push this container to the cloud
but before let's test it again to our
browser
and to test it we have to run it so
docker
run this time we have to specify a port
and the backend port so the container
port is 80
as we said and in the front end
we can put eight eight eight eight not
in the front end in our localhost
and then we have to specify the name of
our container so this is a command
to run this container to port 8888
so it's downloading again because
it's running inside the container and
not sure why
it has this problem now
after i run it again it worked
not sure why it failed uh the first time
and uh it says localhost 80 here but
that is inside the docker container
our local host now 8 000 won't work
as we see but our
port now is 8888
and now we can see hello world now this
hello world
is running inside the docker container
and
that's it we completed the docker
container for this deno app now
let's push it to the cloud i'll also
close
this ide because we don't need it
anymore so i'm logged in now to my
aws management console and we will push
now
our docker container to the elastic
container registry
so i have a shortcut here or we can
search it
so let's go to the container registry
and this is a container registry
let's uh see the repositories so we
don't have any
repositories or registries we have to
create one
so we will push our docker container
here
to have our
regi repository first before we do
anything
make sure to install the aws
cli so go to aws.amazon.com cli
and on the right side here you can
download the windows version
the mac os version or the linux version
so with this you will have
access to your terminal to aws and you
have
several commands that you can use
so now let's first login to
elastic container registry by using this
command
so aws
ecr is elastic container registry
this is a command to login this is the
region
region us2 pipe
docker login the username will be aws
the password will it will be generated
by this one so
that's why is password sdn and
this other url
is like this is our
user id so we can find that if we go to
our account you we have the id here
so that's it and uh
docker.ecr this is also the same
region in amazon aws.com
let's run this command and
we successfully logged in and
now what is left is to push our docker
container to the
elastic container registry so to do that
we have to do docker
tag the name of our container was
up and i will copy
again this url so we have to target
to this url slash in the end
up so the name
should be the same here and this url
will use it a lot so let's talk this
and after we target we have to push it
so uh remove
tag to push
and let's wait till it's completed
so we get an error that the repository
with name
up does not exist so let's create it
we are here at the repositories and
let's create a repository
so this is the same url
and it will be up so
i'm just checking the region if it is
the same
so this will be a private repository
this is a repository name and i will
leave the others by default let's create
this
repository and we created it
so let's push our image now
not here here docker push
and now it's pushing so this will
take some time and the image
will be pushed to the repository
so our image has been pushed so
if we go to our repository we have one
latest
image here the size and everything else
so
we have our image in our repository
i'll copy the uri here for the
repository because
we will need it and now let's go to
amazon container service elastic
container service
ecs and here go to the clusters
and we will create a cluster so
i will select the aws
far gate cluster because it will
take care the managing of the server for
us
if you want to manage your server uh
select this
other one but this is way
easier if we select aws targets
so let's go next the cluster name
so my app
and i will create a default vpc for this
cluster and
i want to select anything else let's
create it
and let's wait till this is completed
so the cluster is created click view
cluster
and now we need a task definition so go
to task
definitions and let's create a new task
definition
so i'll select fargate next step
the task definition name i'll call it up
the role i'll select none
and the network mode i'll select the
default
and for the task memory 0.5 gigabytes
this cpu so i'll select the minimal
versions
and the container here we need to add
the container that we just copied so
this container and the container name
it will be also up uh here we need to
set up the port
so 80 was the port inside the container
so we have to map it here
and we can add also other configurations
but i won't add any so
let's add this and we added our
container there and that's it basically
let's create this
task definition so it was successful
and now let's go to our cluster and uh
here now we can create
our service so this will be also
a fargate we need the task definition
that we created so
amazon will automatically assign it
we need the service name so up
so we have a lot of apps with names
number of tasks i will select one but
you can select two it will create two
containers
uh one it will be only one container so
i will keep everything minimal
but you can select two and
everything should be
okay now so let's go to the next step
subnets i'll select one of these
options and also
assign a public ip yes
load balancer i will select none
and the next step
uh here we can auto scale
but since this is an example i will not
out of scale
so it will be just a simple container
review create service so
everything is created so let's go to the
view service
and let's uh click here
and the status is pending let's wait
till
is running and then after it's running
we will have a public ip which
we will see it let's wait so our task is
running now
and we have a public ip for it so i'll
copy this
ip i'll paste it here and this is
our app so this is how
we deploy a docker container to aws
far gate thank you for watching this
video don't forget to like share and
subscribe
thank you so i'm logged into my azure
portal here
and before i create anything make sure
to have
installed the azure cli so download the
right version for your machine
and follow the instructions you will
have
access to this easy command
which it will show these options
so before
so let's go back to the azure portal
and we'll create a container registry so
we don't have any container registry yet
so let's create a container
registry so
i will create a container registry here
the resource group
i i have a demo research group here
which
i added just the name
the registry name i will call it up so
it needs uh to have a
five characters so i will call it my app
already news so my
container
okay it's container up so which name is
not used
so my container up i
will use this name and
for the location you can pick your
location for this
sku i will select the basic version
let's create it
and we can create
this registry and now that we created
our registry we need also to
login so uh
first we have to log in uh via azure
like this
easy login so we need to sign in to our
account here
and we logged into microsoft azure so
as we can see uh it shows this data
so after we log in there we have to
run this other command so
azure azure container registry
login and here we need the name we chose
which was
up so let's copy it also
so go to the resource and let's copy the
url
which is this one so
we don't need the suffix
so let's login so this will allow us
to push the docker container to
azure so we successfully logged in
and now that we logged in we can
push our image to push our image
first we have to tag the image so docker
tag the name of our container
is up and uh i'll paste again
this url which i copied and
we need to add in the end slash up so
this is
our repository here
so i added this
and after we tag we have to push it so
let's
push it and now it's pushing
our container to the azure
container registry so let's wait till
it's completed
so it is completed now we can go
back and here we'll go to the
repositories this is our app repository
and here we have our image so this is uh
our image and what i will do here
is i will copy this
container name so i'll copy this
and let's go back to home and let's
create a container
instance now so let's create a container
instance
i'll select the same resource group
we need the container name the container
name
is up and we have to
select the image source to azure
container registry
and we have our container app so
we need to enable uh admin here
so let's click learn more
we have to run this command so i will
copy this command
and i will run it here so we need the
name here or i will write it directly
not sure if we need
my container
up
so i made the mistake here it should be
with
1 m not 2 m's
so it is enabled and now we can
use it so do we need to refresh here i
will
refresh and i will select this resource
group
i'll select up here registry and
now it is selected so uh
everything is correct i'll change the
size here i'll keep everything minimal
so
0.5 is a minimal
memory so i'll select this
review and create
also i think i forgot something so
we need to also go to the networking
part
and we have to map the port 80 so by
default
is automatically mapped so we don't have
anything to change
but if your container port is different
we need to
select here the the other part so
80 is correctly and
we don't need to change anything else
let's create it
so deployment is in progress
the deployment is complete so let's go
to the resource
and we have a public ip address here
so we can copy this ip address and
if we go to the ip address we can see
our app
deployed so this is how we deploy a
docker container
to azure contact container instance
thank you for watching this video i hope
you like share and subscribe
thank you so i'm logged in to my google
cloud platform now
and we will we will use two
uh services container registry and cloud
run so let's go to the container
registry
and before adding
anything here we need to install the
google cloud sdk so make sure to
download the right installer
for mac os you download it here
also for windows and linux and also make
sure to add it to your path
once it is completed you can use
gcloud
so i already have my gcloud configured
and now let's uh
log in first so in order to push
containers to the google cloud registry
we have to
be logged in first so gcloud
auth login so
this will connect with our google cloud
account
and we will allow everything
and now we are logged in if we go to our
terminal we will see this so
i'll clear now and now we can
push our image to the docker
registry to the container registry story
so first we have to tag the image so
docker
tag the name of the image is up
and we will target to google cloud
registry so gcr dot io slash
we need the project name so
if we go to our cloud platform
click our project here and this is my
project name so
i'll copy this id here and
i'll add it here so this is our project
id and then we need the name
of our container so this should be the
same
with the last one i tucked
this and then we need to push it
so i'll remove this and we'll push it
and this will push the container to
our google cloud platform so let's wait
till it's completed
so the image is pushed now
we will see the image here so in the
container registry we have our app image
and let's go here and let's copy
the url so i'll copy the url here
because we will need it and let's go to
now to
the cloud run so here we need to create
a service
we need the service name i'll call it up
the region you can select your own
region
we need the container image url so here
we can select it directly
and this is the container the last
container that we pushed so i'll select
this
and this was our container we can add
some advanced settings here
like variable secrets etc but the only
thing that will change
is the port so our container port
is 80 so i'll put 80 here
and we don't need to change anything
else there
next so we need to allow
an unauthenticated invocations so
this is public and that's it
so let's create this
and let's wait till it's completed so it
should be
fast so it is completed
not sure why i made a mistake here the
port was
76 here it should be 80
and we have also a url here
if we go to the url we will see our app
deployed so it was this simple this is
how
we deploy an app to the google cloud
run don't forget to like share and
subscribe
thank you